مشاهدينا تغطيه العربيه مستمره لاحداث
السودان وللشتباكات الدائره هناك حيث
اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع في السودان اليوم
الموافقه على هدنه جديده لمده 24 ساعه
بدات وانتهت منذ ساعه من الان وقوات الدعم
الصعب السريع اعلنت عنها وايدها طبعا
الجيش لكن ومثل سابقاتها لم تكن سوى هدنه
خطابيه احتلت مكانها في بيان عبر الانترنت
وبقيت هناك في الاثناء الصحه السودانيه
اكدت للعربيه ان لا تواصل بينها وبين
الهلال الاحمر والصليل بالاحمر بشان الوضع
الصحي مضيفه لا وجود لمؤشرات على قرب
انهيار النظام الصحي في البلاد رغم ان
تسعه مستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه في انحاء
البلاد وللوضع في السودان انعكاساته
الدوليه فهو اسير الخارجيه السعوديه
ونظيرته الفرنسيه اكد في اتصال هاتفي على
اهميه وقف التصعيد في السودان لتوافق
والدعوه مع دعوات امميه لم تلقى حتى الان
صدى لها في السودان
[موسيقى]
هدنه هشه لا اثر لها على الارض فاصوات
اطلاق النيران ودوي الانفجارات سمعت
باستمرار في مناطق مختلفه من الخرطوم
وتحديدا حول مقر الجيش والقصر الجمهوري
سلسله الاذانات بمسؤوليه خرقها لا زالت
متبادله ليقذف كل منهم كره الاتهام في
ملعب الاخر رغم الجهود الامميه والدوليه
الطرفان المتقاتلان لا يعطيان الانطباع
بانهما يريدان وساطه من اجل السلام بينهما
على الفور ما كنت افعله في اليومين
الماضيين هو محاوله التوسط في توقف انساني
لمده ثلاث ساعات في اليوم
الجيش السوداني فمسؤوليه عن الهدنه الهشه
واكد في بيان له ان قوات الدعم السريع لم
تلتزم بها وهاجمت على مواقع استراتيجيه من
محيط المطار ومبنى القياده العامه السيطره
على هذه المواقع تعد انتصارا كبيرا قد
يحسم بقيه المعارك في المواقع الاخرى وفقا
لخبراء
وبسبب اهميتها القصوى حصن الجيش مركز
القياده من الجهتين الشماليه والغربيه لكن
المعارك اشتدت في الجهتين الجنوبيه
والشرقيه المقابلتين لمطار الخرطوم
قوات الدعم السريع وجهت بدورها ايضا
اتهامات مماثله لقوات الجيش بمخالفه
للقانون الدولي الانساني وقواعد الاشتباك
وخرق الهدنه المتفق عليها ببساطه دوليه
وتبقى الاتهامات متبادله وسط تضارب كبير
في الروايات بين الجانبين سلطان العربيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بعد ساعه من الهدنه التي كان من
المفترض ان تكون هدنه انتقل الان الى
الخرطوم ومراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي لرست
الصوره من على الارض سالم كيف هي الصوره
من هناك وهل ما زلتم يعني ترصدون اصوات
الاشتباك نسمعها على كل حال على الهواء
مباشره
نعم قبل اتصالك هذا بدقيقه واحده كانت
هناك مضادات للطائرات ستنطلق من جهه
كافوري في مربع سته تقريبا في منطقه بحري
هذا يدل على ان الهدنه
من الصعب ان تكون حقيقيه هذه هي المره
الرابعه رابع ما يعلن عنها الطرفين
ثم يجدان صعوبه في تنفيذها على ارض الواقع
هذه هي الحاله الان هدنه كل مره تعلم ومن
ثم يجد كل فريق صعوبه في تنفيذ هذه الهدنه
يعني بالامس كنا نرصد معك بنفس الساعه بعد
ساعه من من الهدنه ايضا كنا نشهد هدنه
متقطعه يعني خفت وتيره المواجهات ونوعيه
الاسلحه بعد الافطار وبعد توقيت الهدنه
بينما كانت وتيره يعني اكبر بكثير قبل
الهدنه الان هل ايضا نتحدث عن هدنه متقطعه
كما امس
نعم هي ذات الهدنه كذلك متقطعه غير مستقره
ما زالت فيها اشتباكات بين الفينه والاخرى
نستمع الى اصوات الرصاص كذلك نستمع الى
اصوات مضادات الطائرات هذا بالاضافه الى
انه اليوم هناك مناطق انتشرت فيها قوات
للدعم السريع لم تكن موجوده فيها من قبل
ما هي هذه المناطق
نعم انا اتحدث عن ارتكازات وليس مناطق
عفوا
ارتكازات
للتفتيش يعني في المؤسسه
اهميه هذه الارتكازات
اهميتها ربما اثبات ان هذه القوه موجوده
على الارض انها هنا في هذه في هذه الشوارع
يعني توقف السيارات
للتفتيش
تتاكد من لكنها لم تشتبك مع المواطنين
لكنها تشكل خطرا لان المواطنين الان
لايجاد واقع امني جديد للمواطنين بين يعني
انقسام المناطق الان بين اماكن تواجد
الدعم السريع واماكن تواجد الجيش كنت كنت
اتحدث عن يعني
وجود نقاط جديده للدعم السريع هذه النقاط
هل تطورت عن الايام الماضيه ام انها
انتقلت من مكان الى اخر
[موسيقى]
نعم هو في الايام الماضيه لم تكن هذه
الارتكازات واضحه للمواطنين على كل حال
خاصه الذين يتحركون يعني بالنسبه للشوارع
التي يتحرك فيها المواطنين عاده عاد
الجسور لان الجسور علما انه يقينا انها
مغلقه لكن بعد ذلك وجد المواطنين ان حتى
الطرق الرئيسه الان في تقاطعتها الرئيسه
بدات تظهر هذه القوات في نقاط واسال
المواطن عن اثبات شخصيته والى اين يذهب
وهل هو ينتمي الى واحده من يعني ينظر الى
تقسيم اذا محل يعني اكمل او استكمل بهذه
الطريقه عاده هكذا يتم تقسيم المدن بين
المناطق بين الفصائل المتحاربه نتحدثون عن
مظاهر الحرب الاهليه اذا صح التعبير ولكن
هنا طبعا الصوره مختلفه مع الجيش سالم هذه
النقاط نقاط التفتيش هل يعني الاعداد
الموجوده كبيره هل تتبدل هل يعني يتم
تبديل بين النقاط التي فيها مواجهات ونقاط
التفتيش
هذه النقاط انا اتحدث عن نقاط جديده
رايتها اليوم حتى نكون اكثر دقه كذلك لكي
لا يفهم هذا الموضوع خطا انا اتحدث عن
نقاط جديده شوارع الايام الماضيه لم تكن
فيها نقاط الان فيها نقاط لقوات الدعم
السريع هذه هي النقطه الملفته للانتباه
وتجعل انه ربما يكون هناك طريقه تفكير
مختلفه لهذه القوه الان هذا ما يفهم لان
هذا الشارع كان يمضي بسلاسه لا توجد فيه
قوات لا الدعم السريع ولا الجيش وكان
المواطنين يخرجون من بعد صلاه العصر يقضون
بعض الاغراض المهمه
والرئيسه ليجتلبوا بها حاجيات الافطار
كذلك الماء لان هناك في مشكله مياه
يجلبون الاشياء فيتحركون في هذه الشوارع
فكانت في الايام الماضيه هذه الشوارع تكون
سالكه عاده عاد انهم يستمعون الى اصوات
الرصاص ويستمعون كذلك
اصوات المسائيات وكذا لكن يتفاجئون اليوم
بان في هذا الشارع نقطتين ارتكازين لقوات
الدعم السريع اثارت رعبا حقيقه عند
المواطنين جعلوا يشتكون ويتحدثون على ان
هذا الامر جديد ربما يفهم انه شكل اخر من
اشكال التصعيد ما هي دلالاته ما هي
تفسيراته هذا شان المختصين في العلم
العسكري
الم معي لو سمحت ساعود اليك مشاهدينا
سانتقل واياكم الى هذه الصور الخاصه بقناه
العربيه
لعمليه استهداف مستشفيات ومراكز صحيه خلال
هذه هذا النهار لتصحيح هو اشتباك بجانب
المستشفيات والمراك الصحيه
[تصفيق]
يا جماعه
عشان اشاره هناك قريب
اعود مجددا مجددا مشاهدينا الى الزميل
سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم
سالم كنا نتحدث عن نقاط الارتكاز الجديده
والتي اثارت حفيظه
الشعب السوداني والمواطنين السودانيين
هناك وطبعا التي تؤسس الى ظواهر امنيه
جديده بظل الاشتباك الدائر مما يعني طول
امد هذا الاشتباك
بالناحيه الاخرى الناحيه الانسانيه الناس
اليوم بحاجه للخروج لتامين الاحتياجات
الاساسيه هذه الهدنه الهشه هل ممكن ان
تؤمن يعني منفذ للمواطنين للخروج ام اننا
نتحدث عن يعني بقائهم عالقين لليوم تقريبا
الخامس على التوالي او اكثر
نعم قبل الحديث على الامر الانساني فقط
نقطه اخيره في هذه الارتكازات يعني لماذا
المواطنون يشعرون بالرعب من مثل هذه
الارتكازات وذات الوقت اذا كانت هذه
الابتك ابيعه على الجيش لا يشعرون بالرعب
لان الجيش ينظر اليه المواطن السوداني
بانه الجيش السوداني الشعب المسلحه بالضبط
وحمايه وهو بالنسبه له بالنسبه له عباره
عن جهه رسميه من حقها ان توقفت وتسالك عن
بطاقتك والى اين تذهب وكذا لكن ان تكون
هناك قوه
ما زالت هذه الصوره موجوده على نعم وهذا
مخيف حقيقه هذا هو محل الذعر الذي يراه
المواطن حينما يجد ارتكاز من ارتكازات
قوات الدعم السريع هذه هي النظره في نظر
المواطن انه الان امام ارتكاز ربما ربما
يصدر منه اي شيء ولا يستطيع ان يعيد حقه
هذه هي المشكله
ايضا هناك في الجانب الانساني هناك
مبادرات جيده بدات عند الشباب منهم جزء في
اللجان المقاومه ومنهم شباب مستقيمين كذلك
بداوا في مبادرات في العمل الانساني من
هذه المبادرات مثلا هناك غرفه الان وانشات
لطوارئ في بحريتها لجان المقاومه وهي تسعه
لجمع
كل الاحتياجات التي بما انك تتحدث عن هذه
المبادره اسمح لي ان انتقل الى محمد حامد
احد اعضاء مبادره اجلاء وهي مبادره تعمل
على اجلاء المرضى والمصابين يعني نستشف
منه اكثر حول هذه المبادره محمد يعني
اليوم انتم اطلقتم هذه المبادره لمحاوله
اجلاء المرضى والمصابين خصوصا ان هناك
صعوبه لوصول الهلال الاحمر وصليب الاحمر
كيف كيف هي وتيره العمل على الارض وما هي
الصعوبات التي تواجهكم
الله سبحانه
الصوت متقطع
[موسيقى]
اذا ممكن اذا امكن يعني تعديل وضعيه
الوقوف او الهاتف
تفضل تفضل
صعب جدا على مستوى المستشفيات نحن الان
شغالين على مستشفيات الرئيسيتين
هي مستشفى القياده العامه للجيش السودان
وهي اكثر المناطق يعني حراره الان في
السودان المنطقه دي هي فيها
الاطلاق نار كثيف جدا هذا
يعني يعرض الكثير من المواطنين
بهذه المستشفيات في خطر والحقيقه حصلت
يعني بعض الاصابات
في في
بعضكم منهم طبيه ولا
المرافقين وايضا مربى كذلك الان نحن يعني
اشتغلنا عمليه اجلال العديد من المرضى من
مستشفى الشعب لمستشفى مجاور اليهود اللي
هو مستشفى الخصوم يعني
احنا يعني
او اماكن بعيده نتيجه لانه الطرق غير امنه
توفر وسائل
ابقى معي ابقى معي لو سمحت نعم ساعود الى
اليك بما انك تتحدث عن وسائل النقل وعن
يعني الاوضاع هناك ايضا مشاهدينا كان هناك
عدد
من التفجيرات منها مطال السيارات سينضم
الي بشير ابراهيم بدوي وهو شاهد عيان من
الخرطوم
ابراهيم بشير هل ممكن ان تطلعنا على
تفاصيل هذا التفجير من فجر لماذا هل هو
دافع امني ام ان الاشتباك بفعل الاشتباك
اولا نزل الله
هذا البلاء
ويوقف الحرب ان شاء الله
الرحمه لجميع الموت الشفاء للجرحى
حدث كان ما بين الساعه السابعه الثامنه
في شارع الستين
بالغرب من مبنى البشاري الديكور سابقا شرق
السوبر ماركت عماره سنتر كان الغذائف
طائشه يعني ما كانت موجهه بهدف معين لانه
شارع 60 ما كان فيه اي نوع من الاشتباك من
اول يوم لحد اليوم ما كان فيه
لحد اللحظه من الاشتباك كانت طائشه كانت
بتقع داخل الاحياء
فالوظيفه دي وقعت في شارع الستين
الاسره متجهه من الطائف الى شني
بتتكون من ابو وامه
واهو الاثنين وبنته وزوجته ابنه
الرئيس
اخترق السياره وماتوا الابن وزوجه الابنه
في الحال وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن قذائف
ورصاص طائش
يسقط على الاحياء الشعبيه
بشير يعني بموازاه هذه الحادثه هل يعني
كيف هو الوضع على الارض انتم كمواطنين
اليوم ما الذي تعانونه
الرصاص الذي ينزل الاصابات هل هناك جثث
مثلا بالشوارع بالقرب من مكان الذي تقطن
فيه
الرصاص واظائف بكثافه يعني في منطقه
الجريف بالتحديد وفي الوظيفه الاولى وحده
سقطت
الحمد لله
وظيفه الثالثه فيها
وفيات من ضمنهم اجنبي سوري
والغذيفه الرابعه هي كانت في اليسرى
السودانيه
هل باستطاعتكم الخروج لتامين الاحتياجات
الاساسيه نحن نتحدث عن خرق الهدن يعني لا
هدنه يلتزم بها الطرفان كيف تؤمنون المواد
الاساسيه اتحدث عن الغذاء هناك انقطاع
للكهرباء وللماء يعني كيف تعيشون
اه والله
ما في ما في خطه معينه لتعليم والماء ولكن
الناس بتساند بعض يعني كل من يحتاج يستغيث
فالناس بتستجيب رغم الغوص ورغم الضريبه
قاعدين نتحرك ما قاعدين نتوكل على الله
ومن لسانه بعض يعني شكرا لك بشير ابراهيم
بدوي شاهد عياننا حدثتنا من الخرطوم ننتقل
مشاهدينا الى هذه الصور التي بثها الجيش
لتواجد عناصره في مقر القياده العامه
للجيش في الخرطوم فلنتابع واعود
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا اعيد واكرر هذه الصور التي
نشرها الجيش السوداني من داخل مقر القياده
العامه حيث عناصر الجيش موجودين داخل مبنى
القياده العامه وطبعا للتذكير بان القتال
الاساسي ينحصر الان بمحيط القياده العامه
اذا هذه الصور من داخل مبنى القياده
العامه للجيش طبعا
تثبت وتبرهن سيطره الجيش على الداخل على
المبنى الرئيسي في الخرطوم اذا الاشتباكات
للتفكير هي دائره بمحيط هذه النقطه بمحيط
مبنى القياده العامه ما زالت حتى الساعه
وهنا هذه الصور تؤكد وجود الجيش داخل مبنى
القياده العامه
والله العيد عيدين الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر وريه وريه
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الدعامه
الدعامه
وين العيد العيد
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا تابعنا واياكم هذه الصور
الاحتفاليه لعناصر من الجيش السوداني اثرى
تواجدهم داخل المبنى الرئيسي للقياده
العامه
السودانيه طبعا
القتال كما ذكرنا ينحصر بمحيط مبنى
القياده هذه الصور تثبت وجود الجيش في
الداخل وطبعا سيطره الجيش على مبنى
القياده العامه حتى اللحظه مع محاولات
التقدم السريع حتى الساعه
للدخول الى هذا المبنى
اعود مشاهدينا الى محمد حامد قعد احد
اعضاء مبادره اجلاء وهي مبادره تعمل على
اجلاء المرضى والمصابين محمد يعني كنت
تقول لي بانكم تعملون على نقل المصابين
والمرضى بظل صعوبه وصول الصليب الاحمر او
الهلال الاحمر طبعا السوداني الى الداخل
ولكن هناك تحديات اساسيه اليوم هي موضوع
نقص المواد داخل المستشفيات خروج
المستشفيات عن الخدمه وعدم وجود كوادر
طبيه بسبب يعني الاشتباكات الدائره ماذا
تفعلون وكيف تتعاطون مع هذا الامر
نعم للاسف الان يعني
صوره كبيره جدا على مستوى
اشخاص متواجدين في انحاء هذه المواصفات
العمل في مواصفات العلاجيه محمد بما اننا
نتحدث عن بما اننا نتحدث عن نقص المواد
الطبيه والكوادر الطبيه ساتابع واياك
والمشاهدين هذه الصور الخاصه بقناه
العربيه
من داخل مستشفى ام درمان لنقل طبعا الوضع
الصحي من هناك
اذا على ما يبدو كما نتابع بالصوره يعني
المستشفى وضع مختلف عن المستشفيات الاخرى
التي تابعناها قبل قليل داخل الخرطوم
المستشفى يعني في حاله تشغيليه جيده هناك
وجود للعاملين وايضا يعني ليس هناك حاله
فوضى
اعود اليك محمد محمد مستشفى ام درمان على
ما يبدو وضعه جيد ليس كباقي المستشفيات هل
لديكم اعداد تقريبيه عن المستشفيات التي
ما زالت صالحه للخدمه وقادره على تامين
الرعايه الصحيه للمصابين الذين تحاولون
اجلائهم
بالاضافه للمستشفى خاصه
بالنساء وتوليد هذه المستشفيات التي تعمل
الان الصور التي تمها قبل قليل لمركز
في عام مختلفه من العاصمه
نتحدث عن عدد قليل من المستشفيات مقارنه
مع الحاجه الهائله
لوجود مستشفيات اكثر يعني
بالخدمه وايضا لمستلزمات طبيه وغيرها شكرا
لك محمد حامد احد اعضاء مبادره اجلاء وهي
طبعا مبادره تعمل على اجلاء المرضى
والمصابين في الخرطوم
اعود مشاهدينا او انتقل الان الى مدينه
مروي وينضم الى مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي
نزار كيف هي الصوره من هناك بعد حوالي
الساعه والنصف على الهدنه المعلنه
الاوضاع هنا في مروي مختلفه بعض الشيء عما
يدور في العاصمه الخرطوم وفي عدد من
المناطق
مروي الان
يعلوها الهدوء مساء بعد ان كانت يوم الامس
وامس الاول
تشهد حاله من التوتر والحاله من الخلف
نتيجه
استخداميه او الطلعات الجويه التي وصلت
الى القاعده الجويه والى مطار مروي
والان الوضع يمضي نحو الهدوء خاصه بعد ان
اعلن الجيش السوداني بانه قوات الدعم
السريعه الان اصبحت خارج مروي وخارج
المنطقه بعد ان تعامل معها عسكريا وتم
استخدام الطائرات حسب شهود العيان الذين
قالوا بان قوات الدعم السريع مضت نحو
الاتجاهات الجنوبيه لمحليه ندوي الان
الاوضاع هادئه مستقره
حاله من الهدوء تسوء هذه المدينه
بظل هذا الهدوء هل يعني رفضتم خلال هذا
النهار او خلال ساعات الليل الاولى اي
تحركات لعناصر من
الدعم السريع خصوصا وانها تعودنا بالايام
الماضيه ان تعود خلال ساعات الليل ويحصل
مناوشات بين الطرفين بعد احكام السيطره
على قاعده مروي هل تغيرت الصوره
المشهد كما هو منذ ان اعلن الجيش السوداني
بان قوات الدعم السريع اضطرت الى ان تخرج
من القاعده
بعد ان تم استخدام المدفعيه الثقيله وتم
استخدام الطيران العسكري
ليس الان اي اشارات تؤكد بان هنالك تحركات
خلال اليوم او الساعات التي نعيشها الان
بقوه الدعم السريع في منطقه مروي كل
التاكيدات التي صدرت منذ الامس وحتى الان
تشير وتؤكد بالدلائل بان الجيش الان هو من
يمسك بزمام الامر في مروي
وفي المطار وفي القاعده القوات تنتشر
المدفعيه موجوده الاليات العسكريه منتشره
في محيط المطار
حاله من الاستعداد ما زالت ما في لوحه
حاضره في نووي لكن هي حرب هي عمليات
تكتيكيه لكن ما يؤكد عليه هنا حسب القاده
العسكريين بان الجيش
سيتعامل مع كل سيناريوهات مع كل التحركات
لكن ايضا نؤكد عبر تصريحات ايضا لبعض
العسكريين وبعض المصادر بان الامور وفق
الجيش ايضا تمضي نحو الاستقرار والهدوء
خاصه في هذه المنطقه هنا في الشمال في
محليه مروي بما ان الوضع هذا ميدانيا
وعسكريا على الارض الناس هناك هل اصبحوا
بوضع افضل هل يعني يستطيعون قضاء حاجياتهم
الاساسيه بالخروج والعوده الى منازلهم
ماذا عن الامدادات الغذائيه والصحيه
الى هذه المنطقه
يعني خلال ملاحظاتنا نهار وعصر هذا اليوم
السوق الرئيس في مدينه مروي بدات تعود
اليه الحياه
التجاريه والاقتصاديه بعض الشيء بعض
المحاله التجاريه اعاده فتح ابوابها من
جديد حركه المواصلات تم استئنافها
مساء الامس وصباح اليوم وظهر اليوم في
ساعات المساء دائما مشهد حاله من الهدوء
في مدينه مروي بحكم ايضا حاله الهدوء
النسر وحاله التوتر التي كانت سائده خلال
الايام الماضيه لكن خلال هذا اليوم بدا
الاستقرار يمضي في درجات متسارعه هنالك
حاله من الهدوء في اوساط المواطنين هنالك
طمانين الان سرت في جثه هذه المدينه
هنالك بشريات الان بدات تلوح حتى في ملامح
السكان من خلال التحركاتهم من خلال تفقدهم
لبعضهم البعض
من خلال التجوالهم بين القرى المحيطه
بالقاعده والمطار هذا الامر كان مقتصرا
فقط على الحركه الداخليه هنا في مروي ولكن
اليوم لاحظنا تنقل عبر الجسر الذي يربط
بين مدينتي مروي وكريمه وحتى بان مواطنين
قدموا من مدينه عبره في الجهه الشرقيه من
ولايه نهر النيل قدموا الى كريمه والى
مروي ومن منها الى دنبله ما يعني ان
الحركه الان بدات تعود الى طبيعتها لكن
ايضا المطالبات من قبل المواطنين بان تمتد
سيطره القوات المسلحه حتى لا تعاد الكره
مره اخرى وتدخل المدينه في اوتون الصراع
كانت جزء منه وهي تشاهد العمليات العسكريه
على مقربه من المدينه
نزار بالايام الاولى كان هناك حركه نزوح
كما في الخرطوم الان بمدينه مروي هل رصدتم
عوده لبعض الناس
الذين ربما اخلوا بيوتهم الى اماكن قريبه
او الى خارج المدينه هل بالرغم من عوده
يعني الهدوء هناك خوف ونزوح من المنطقه ام
ام لا
ليس هنالك نزوح بالمعنى المطلق لهذه
الكلمه الاسره التي تقطم بالقرب من
القاعده خلال ثلاثه ايام او الاربعه ايام
الماضيه المنصمه تخوفت من حالات القصف
المستمر ومن الطلعات الجويه التي كانت
تحلق في سماء المدينه
اسر كثيره اثرت ان تمضي نحو عمق المدينه
الى الاحياء المتاخمه لنهر النيل منهم من
عبر الى مناطق في الجانب الاخر من المدينه
خلف الجسر شاهدنا ظهرا هذا اليوم اعداد
ايضا مقدره من الاسر بدات تعود الى بيوتها
الى منازلها الى مساكنها بعد ان استشعرت
حاله الاستقرار والطمانينه التي سرقت في
المدينه بعد ان احكم الجيش سيطرته كما اكد
ذلك في المداخل والمخارج
شكرا مصاص شارفت يومها الخامس على
الانتهاء وشارف طبعا يوم الخامس على
الانتهاء وفيما الاشتباكات تتواصل تتزايد
المخاوف من توسع رقعه النزاع ليدق اسوار
الدول المجاوره ويزعزع امن هذه الدول
فلنتابع
حرب الازقه والشوارع معديه وقد تتسرب شيئا
فشيئا لحاره مجاوره واخره لها طالما ان
الجنراللين سقطا بمحظور الاقتتال الداخلي
فخ اوقع بدول محيطه منذ سنوات انها شخص
اقتصادها وافقر شعوبها
السودان لحق بالركب ولم يفته القطار دوله
شلها غياب المركزيه السياسيه والعسكريه
كما جيرانها ليبيا وسوريا ولبنان حيث
يفترض انها دول مستقله تتمتع بالسياده وحق
تقرير المصير اي دول ديجوري وفق القانون
الدولي لكنها وجدت نفسها على الجانب الاخر
من القائمه دول مسلوبه القرار ومهمشه بحكم
الواقع او دي فاكتور
هذه الفوضى الداخليه مرميه على حافه
التوسع بحكم موقع السودان الجيو السياسي
بالغ الاهميه فالوضع السوداني يهدد بنشر
الفوضى في دول مجاوره وعيسى في بعضها فساد
بالاصل ارتريا واثيوبيا من الشرق تشاد
وليبيا من الغرب وصولا الى مصر من الجهه
الشماليه فمن شان اي اضطراب في السودان ان
يزعزع امنها القومي ويضر بحصصها المائيه
مع سعي اثيوبيا لتعبئه سد النهضه السودان
يطل كذلك على البحر الاحمر الذي يربط اهم
ممرين بحريين هما باب المندب وقناه السويس
ما يزيد مغريات الدوله الذهبيه الكثيره في
عيون دول كبرى بينها روسيا وتركيا فحلم
القاعده البحريه هناك تتشاركه الدولتان
حرب الجنرالين تمتلك الخلطه الناجحه
والسريعه للحرب الاهليه للاشتباكات طويله
الامد وتوزعها على مساحات واسعه وامكانيه
انزلاق الحركات المسلحه الاخرى الى المشهد
اما الحل السياسي المامول فبايد ليست
متوفره حاليا بل ممدوده الى اوكرانيا
وتايوان حل لن يكون مغيرا عن سابقه
الخجوله قبل اندلاع حرب اللا منتصر اي
خساره الطرفين وانتقال القياده لطرف ثالث
[موسيقى]
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مشاهدينا اللواء
الدكتور امين اسماعيل مجذوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي في مركز الدراسات الدوليه
استاذ دكتور امين سابدا من التطورات على
الارض مع احكام سيطره الجيش السوداني على
نقطتين استراتيجيتين اتحدث عن الابيض وعن
مروي الان الصراع دائر حول القاعده
الاساسيه هنا يعني المعلوم بان الجيش لن
يتوقف ولن يوقف هذه العمليه قبل التفكيك
الكامل لقوات الدعم السريع هل باستطاعتي
حازم هذا الموضوع وعدم انتقاله الى حرب
كانتونات وحرب يعني مناطق داخليه
مساء الخير مرحب بك ومرحب بالساده
المشاهدين
حقيقه اليوم بدات ان المرحله الثالثه
المرحله الاولى كانت تصدى الهجوم مرحله
الثانيه كانت
قتال الشوارع اليوم المطارده بدات
المطارده في كل النقاط بما فيها
مروي تطهير مطار مرغي تطهير المبيض
والان الهدنه واضح انه من يخلق الهدنه هو
الذي يهاجم القياده العامه يعني ما تحتاج
الى توضيح دائما
بيمنع الممرات العالقه عموما القوات
المسلحه تحاول
اسمح لي ان اشير الى ان اعلام مصري رسمي
يتحدث عن وصول الدفعه الاولى الدفعه
الاولى من العسكريين المصريين المحتجزين
في السودان الى القاهره اذا للتفكير
مشاهدينا هؤلاء العسكريين كان قد احتجزهم
الدعم السريع عند دخوله الى قاعده مروي
عندما كانت قوه من الجيش المصري موجوده
هناك لعمليات تدريب مشتركه بين الجيش
المصري وبين الجيش السوداني اعود اليك
دكتور امين
لذلك القوات المسلحه في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا وسط الخرطوم تستخدم اقل قوه ممكنه
وبتركيز شديد نسبه لوجود عدد من
المستشفيات عدد من المناطق السكنيه
وبالتالي تستغل القوات الدعم السريع هذه
النقطه تذهب وتعود وتنسحب وتعود مره اخرى
لمهاجمه القياده العامه
وتركت بقيه المناطق وان كان مطار او
الغفره الرئاسي الذي فقدته تماما
ظهر اليوم لذلك
قدره الاقوات المسلحه على حسب الصراع كما
فضلته في سؤالك مساله الحسم الصراع في حرب
المدن وقدار الشوارع تعتمد على اعتبارات
كثيره منها وجود المدنيين
دعامي كبير جدا ايضا الخدمات احيانا
القوات المسلحه عن بعض العمل حتى تسمح
للاديان
الخطوات توفر الامداد توفر
الاحتياجات اللوجستيه مواد تمويل القتال
النفس الطويل اللي هي العزيمه انا اعتقد
انه الان قوات الدعم السريع
ليس بينها اتصال مع قيادتها وهذا الذي
يجعل التصرفات الخرديه
دكتور امين ايضا يعني عدم وجود اتصال
وترابط هذا يؤدي الى نوع من الانفلات وهو
ايضا خطير ولكن سانتقل الى جانب اخر وهو
السؤال الاساسي الذي يطرح اليوم الى من
يعني تميل موازين القوى ان كان على الارض
وان كان بالامكانات من المعلوم بان الجيش
السوداني يعني منذ تحرير السودان منذ
استقلال السودان خاضع العديد من الحروب
والانقلابات ولدي انحاءازات اقتصاديه ضخمه
ولكن بالوقت نفسه الدعم السريع يسيطر على
مصدر الاساسي للذهب وللتصدير للخارج
ولديهم مصالح مع دول خارجيه هل هذه
المصالح ممكن ان تؤدي الى حسابات معقده
بالداخل تطيل امد يعني الازمه
هذا التطور وهذه العلاقات وهذا التطور
الاقتصادي للدعم السريع للاسف تم بمباركه
النظام السابق وخلال الاربع سنوات الماضيه
وكان مراقب تحت سمع وبصر السلطه الموجوده
لذلك الان من السهوله تحييت هذه
الفائقه نتحدث عن علاقات مع روسيا نتحدث
عن العلاقات مع دول في الجوار الجغرافي
لكن يمكن تحيدها باعتبار انه في تلك
الفتره الدعم لا يتجزا من المكون العسكري
الحاكم ولكن بعد الخلافه الاخير واتخاذ
الطريق المواجهه يمكن تحديد
وايضا لا ننسى انه الله الحكومه السودانيه
الموجوده لديها
الخارجيه يمكن ان تضغط بها حتى لا يتطور
الامر الى حرب اهليه مدعومه من الخارج
مهم جدا الان
كل الفرضيات تتجه الى خروج الدعم السريع
بعد التخريب الذي يمارسه الان الى خارج
الخرطوم والالتحاق باقليم دارفور حيث
الحاضن الشعبيه والقبليه ويمكن ان يكون
هنالك ازمه جديده في تاريخ السودان لكن
خروجه خروجه من داخل الخرطوم
وعودته الى اقليم دارفور هذا لا يعني ان
الازمه الداخليه في السودان انتهت وانما
يعني ازمه
متقطعه ويمكن ان يعودوا باي لحظه وايضا
هذا يعني بان يعني الواقع سيبقى حدا دكتور
هناك نقطه ايضا وهو موضوع
ما اذا فعلا يعني حصل هذا السيناريو
تداعيات ذلك على الحدود الليبيه وتشاديه
ماذا ما هي تداعيات هذا الموضوع هناك مع
الانفلات الذي سيحصل مع التداخل القبلي
الموجود هناك
الدول الجوار الغربي تعاني من ازمات
الاربع دول الموجوده في الشريط الغربي
يعاني من ازمات واذا حدث في دارفور اي رزق
او ازمه مسلحه او حتى حركه مسلحه
هذا يعني انقراض الامن في تلك الدول لان
فيها معارضات والدودان كان محايد في
الصراع بضاعه اذا استودعنا البحر غير
محايد بوجود حركه مسلحه في الحدود هذا
يعني انفراد عقده تلك الدول وهذا ما تخشاه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي ومجلس الامن ان هنالك السبعه
الدول بها عزمات محيطه بالسودان اذا حصل
اي ازمه في السودان السبعه دول ستنهار حتى
من دول الساهل حتى دول الغردقه الافريقي
ومعلوما ان هنالك مشاكل قوميه في دول
الشركه السودان دولتين في مشاكل قوميات
نفس المشكله الاسميه والقبليه فاذا وجدت
انه ما في هيئه الحدود او في مساعدات
مفتوحه او طريق امداد اكيد سيكون هنالك
ازمات
تفوق ازمه السودان يمكن ان ان يحذف ازمه
خصوصا ان هناك توقعات ان تدخل ايضا
مجموعات تساند الدعم السريع وبسبب التدخل
مقابله بين بين اطراف هذه الدول شكرا لك
دكتور امين اسماعيل مجذوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي في مركز الدراسات الدوليه
وصل قذائف والقصف المستمر منذ خمسه ايام
تتفجر الازمات الانسانيه بالسودان واحده
تلو الاخوه فلنتبع تفاصيل
بعد غروب الشمس تتناول هذه الاسره
السودانيه الفاتوره في لحظه صمت تنقطع فيه
اصوات المدافع ويرتفع صوت الاذان في
استراحه قصيره من الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع
الضائقه الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها السودان
منذ سنوات يسعى المواطنون لتجاهلها ولو
مؤقتا على مائده الافطار حيث باتت واقعا
يؤرقهم لا يمكنهم توقع تبعاته في ظل
القتال المحتدم
وبالرغم من انهم ربما تجاهلوا بشكل مؤقت
مشاكلهم الاقتصاديه الا نسمات الغذاء التي
تلوح في الافق اصبحت حقيقه واقعه في
السودان استمرار القتال تسبب في تفاقم
الوضع الانساني المتازم بالفعل 15 مليون
شخص بالكاد تتوفر لديهم مستلزمات الغذاء
الاساسيه بحسب تقرير للامم المتحده
تقارير اخرى تشير الى ان نحو اربعه ملايين
طفل دون الخامسه يعانون من بوادر سوء
التغذيه المعارك الدائره حاليا الحقت
اضرارا مباشره في البنيه التحتيه عائلات
بالكامل استبدلت المشروبات الرمضانيه
بالمياه بعدما استهدفت محطات المياه في
بعض الاحياء مثل بحر شمالي الخرطوم
عائلات اخرى لجات الى الاكتفاء بوجبه
واحده فقط في اليوم في سبيل التعايش مع
الظروف الصعبه الاحياء الاوفر حظا يقتنص
سكانها فرصه هدوء الاشتباكات ليهرعوا الى
محلات البقاله ليجدوا ارففها فارغه تماما
خاصه التي تحتوي على المياه المعدنيه
بالنسبه لاغلاق الطعم لسوبر ماركت
والدكاكين
السيناريو الاكثر سوءا الذي لم يتوقعه
السودانيون كان اعلان برنامج الغذاء
العالمي وقف مساعداتي للبلاد على وقع مقتل
ثلاثه من موظفيه نتيجه الاشتباكات بين
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله
مشاهدينا سينضم الي الان من الخرطوم بحري
الصحافه عمار ابو شيبه للحديث عن التطورات
هناك عمار هل لديك اي معطيات عن الطائره
العسكريه المصريه دعني اشير الى هذه
المصادر مصادر العربيه طائره عسكريه مصريه
هبطت في السودان مع بدء الهدنه وتسلمت
عسكريين مصريين نحن نتحدث عن اول دفعه من
العسكريين المصريين الذين سلمهم الدعم
السريع الى القوات المصريه هل لديك اي
معطيات عن هذا الموضوع
طبعا هذه المعلومه خرجت الان يعني نشرت
بان الدفعه من العسكريين المصريين الذين
كانوا قوات الدعم السريع في المطار او
قاعده مرض العسكريه تم تسليمه الان او
وصولهم للقاهره
هذه
المعلومه التاكد والتعرف اكثر حول هذه
الفرضيه او هذه المعلومه ولكن بحسب
تضمينات كثيره جدا لقاده قوات الدعم
السريع في الفتره الفائته بان القوات او
العسكريين المصريين قادهم بخير وكثير من
الفيديوهات التي خرج
ت
للقاهره هنا في منطقه بحثي يعني قبل قليل
هنالك مضادات ارضيه كثيره جدا كانت في
سماء بحري لطائرات
من غير طيار طائره اصطناعيه ما بين الفيله
والاخرى شاهدنا ذلك قبل قليل يعني باتجاه
الغرب باتجاه معسكر مظلات لقوات الدعم
السريع وباتجاه الشرق في المدينه ايضا
معسكر او مجموعه من القوات تتحكم في هذه
المنطقه
يعني
بموازاه هذه اسمح لي ايضا ان اشير الى
العاجل قبل ان اكمل الامم المتحده
والجامعه العربيه والاتحاد الافريقي في
قمه عن بعد غدا حول السودان اذا
سيتم عقد قمه عن بعد بين كل من الامم
المتحده الجامعه العربيه والاتحاد
الافريقي لبحث ازمه السودان طبعا يعني
اليوم كان هناك امال بان تكون هذه الهدنه
التي اعلن عنها والتي لم يلتزم بها
الطرفان ان تكون بادره حسينيه كما كانت
الامال بالامس ولكن على ما يبدو هناك تعنت
لانهاء هذه العمليه من قبل احد الطرفين
اليوم بموازين القوى على الارض ماذا تقول
خذنا هشه وهذه الهشاشه التي فيها ربما
قعدتها
لا تصب اكثر من ساعه او ساعتين بحسب ما
رايتها المؤتمر ذكرت
يها ذكرتها التقلي
د ربما لصعوبه
داخل السودان وربما لصعوبه التواصل ما بين
الصحراءين الان في الخرطومة النظامي
ومجموعه
قوات
الجيش وخرجت عن المنظومه العسكريه حسب ما
ذكر العسكريون في الجيش السوداني
للوصول نحو هدف يمكن من خلاله التوصل الى
قليل من ريبوتشات النظر معلوم ان التفاوض
الان يصعب ان يكون والمعركه في حديتها
ربما التفاوض يكون حينما يملك اي طرف اخر
ارضيه اكثر على ارض الواقع الجيش يصرح
ببيانات كثيره بانه ضد هجوما والدعم
السريع يصرح بانه يسيطر او يسيطر على بعض
الاماكن الاستراتيجيه داخل عاصمه
لم تنتهي لدى عبير من القوات ربما الان
على الارض احكم معركه تكسير العظام
بعدها يمكن ان نذهب الى تفاوض وربما هنالك
تمرير لاجندات سياسيه من خلال المؤتمر
الذي يجمع صيامه غدا باذن الله
اذا بانتظار يعني هذا المؤتمر غدا
وبانتظار عمليات الحسم على الارض لنرى كيف
ستكون هذه الصوره طبعا غد الايام القادمه
ستكون مفصليه بهذا النزاع اليوم عمار يعني
السودان تعتبر واحد من افقر دول العالم
بالرغم من انها من اكبر المصدرين
والمنتجين للذهب بافريقيا ولكن معظم انتاج
الذهب هناك يهرب عبر الجماعات التي تستولي
على هذه المناجم الواقع الاقتصادي يقول
بان الخسائر اليوميه هي اكثر من نصف مليار
كل يوم بهذا النزاع ماذا يعني كل هذا على
الواقع السوداني في حال ما بقي النزاع
قائم حتى وان خرجت قوات الدعم السريع الى
خارج العاصمه الخرطوم
وتلغي
لا احد يستطيع ان يتكلم عن منظومه
اقتصاديه طالما ان هناك حرب على ارض
الواقع لا احد يستطيع ان يتكلم عن اصلاحات
لطالما ان هنالك حرب على ارض الواقع
دائما تخسر منها الشعوب لا احد يربح
بالحروف
الاقتصادي ما نراه يعني المواطنون يشكون
بالكثير جدا من المشكلات الاقتصاديه ومن
التردد المعيشي كانت هذه شكوى حتى يعني في
ايام الحكومه الانتقاليه الاولى وحتى في
حكومه
مخلوع البشير
شعب الكثير جدا من الاجراءات الاقتصاديه
التي راها الشعب بانها تضيق عليه العيش
ومن ثم الحكومه الانتقاليه كانت هنالك
وكل هذا حتى وصلنا الى هذه النقطه نقطه
الحرب وما فيها من كثير جدا من تطلعات في
الجانب الا وربما ثوابت يعني الان اصبح
المجتمع يسلم بها لا احد الان
يتحدث الر
غيف العيش او او قفه الملاحظه في السودان
ما في واحد بيتكلم عن الحاجات الان بشكل
واضح كل الحديث الاقتصاد الان انه
ان يخرج من هذه الابطال لمن ان يذهب الى
منطقه اكثر امانا معلوم ان الوضع
الاقتصادي للفتره في السودان
يشدد من المناحي وانت ذكرتي بان
اثار الانتاج صور انتاجا فيما يخص
الاقتصاد المحلي او الناتج المحلي ولكن
التحدي الاساسي ان يؤمن
بظل كل الصعوبات الموجوده
والامن والامان وكل ما الى ذلك شكرا لك
استاذ عمار على هذه المداخله
وضع انساني يتفاقم بتفاقم الازمه التي
يشهدها السودان والاسوا هو صعوبه تلبيه
الخدمه الانسانيه والصحيه الاساسيه في خضم
الصراع الدموي الذي تشهده البلاد والذي
ادى بحياه 185 شخصا واصابه 1800 وفق الامم
المتحده اما نقابه اطباء السودان فقد
اعلنت عن 174 حاله وفاه واكثر من 1200
اصابه حصيله اعتبارها السكان في الخرطوم
اقل من اعداد الضحايا على ارض الواقع
حصار لايام حرم الاهالي في الخرطوم وما
حولها من معظم الخدمات الاساسيه ما يصعب
تقديم العون على منظمات الاغاثه بحسب
الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيه الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر والذي اكد على وجود
الامكانات لكن انعدام الممرات الانسانيه
هو ما عرقل الوضع
الحصار تجاوز البر الى الجو ليكون اغلاق
مطار السودان وجميع الاجواء السودانيه حجر
عثره اخرى في وجه المساعدات بحسب صحيفه
الكورديان
ازمه طلعت القطاع الصحيه ايضا لتكون
المشافي في مرمى النيران فقد اغلقت 39 من
اصل تسعه وخمسين مشفا في الخرطوم ومحيطها
الابواب امام الجرحى والمرضى بسبب تضرر
البنيه التحتيه الصحيه وفق النقابه اطباء
السودان
حقيقه الوضع الانساني وضع كارثه والنظام
الصحي الان يمكننا ان نقول
تماما يظل تعرض عدد من المستشفيات للقصف
والمباشر وخروجها عن الخدمه
ادانتها منظمه صحه العالميه مسميه اياها
انتهاكا خطيرا معلنه مقتل ثلاثه على الاقل
من العاملين في المجال الصحي بالاضافه
لتوقف عشرات المشاف عن العمل
الهجمات على مرافق الرعايه الصحيه انتهاك
صارخ للقانون الدولي والحق في الصحه ويجب
وقفها على الفور اطباء بلا حدود التي
انشات مشما في دارفور خلال 48 ساعه
استقبلت ما يقارب 136 جريحا توفي منهم 11
شخصا متاثرين بجراحهم
كما ابدت المنظمات قلقها من نقص المعدات
الطبيه الذي قد يودي بحياه المزيد وما زاد
من عبء مهامها اعتراض المقاتلين في
الخرطوم لسيارات الاسعاف التي تنقل الجرحى
او حتى الجثث اذا عمر العربيه
العربيه والحدث في هذا اليوم الاربعاء
التاسع عشر من ابريل لعام 2023 داخل قاعده
مروي الجويه وداخل مطار مروي الدولي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اختم معكم هذه الساعه من التغطيه
للاحداث الدائره في السودان لكن تغطيه
العربيه مستمره والان الى منتهى لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات